And now we're back to the final project, and this
is the fun part. So this is where you should
go through your app, to find opportunities for contextual awesomeness,
and then, keep searching for inspiration. This may mean researching Google
Play services more or checking out the repository of awesomeness.
But once you've figured out something out that you think you
can do that you really add to your app, add
call outs to your prezzy that will help other people understand
what that awesomeness is. And of course, you must obey
the two prime directives, which are to always be purposeful and
respectful. Just because a feature exists doesn't mean you need to
put it in. And of course, don't be creepy. Good luck.